reste un petit peu derrière ce n'est
debout comme il a cité place pour vous
on se retrouve accusé 22h ce soir salut
je crois que j'ai peut-être essayer de
sortir avec romane sens je crois que
j'ai peut-être essayer la conquérante
j'ai pas envie ton anniversaire le coni
a pris du retard je t'aime je t'aime en
ciment
moi dû payer les factures d'électricité
rhmani
mais la guitare
pendant ces cinq secondes romane bilal
et victor ont disparu et ce type est
apparu à la fin ça
comme s'ils s'étaient évaporés
non c'est milla
c'est une réelle différence mais c'est
la même en train tôt
si j'aurais j'entends ça veut dire que
romane et victor aussi
visser victoire et moi c'est romaine
vous souvenez du triangle des bermudes
[Musique]
oh punaise